Wow.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Foreign
[Silence]
forch.
Naba men and
Sam.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
We have here a narration on the
authority of Ibas.
This is
of course in the chapter of patience.
Now we have another type of patience.
Patience. We've gone through many levels
and types of patience. We mentioned that
patience
when mentioned in the Quran and Sunnah
is a reference
to three places. Patience upon three
things. Number one, patience upon the
obedience of Allah. The second patient.
Patience in abstaining from the
prohibitions of Allah. Number three,
exhibiting patience
in enduring
the trials and tribulations of the
decree of Allah. What is decreed upon a
person even if it's good good decree or
what seems to be good fortune
seems to be something that a person
wouldn't have to endure. However, many
people's dean, many people's
righteousness is extinguished by
seemingly good fortune, wealth, comfort,
etc., luxury.
And so here we have another dynamic of
that patience.
Narrates that the messenger of Allah
said indeed there will be after me after
me.
Meaning after my death after my
departure and the departure of my legacy
in its most permanent sense. And that
would be after the time of
the decades after him of
because the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam.
He told us that the
after him would be 30 years
after this
after these decades of his meaning his
successorship. Those who are successors
to the prophet,
those are Abu Bakr and Omar and Ali.
40 years of
successorship.
After those 40 years came to an end, we
have what we have. He is he said after
that it will turn into a kingship, a
kingdom just any other kingdom.
And so we see that after these four,
this was the end of the
in the sense of direct descendants of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and it
turned into a kingship into an empire.
Now the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam says in this narration
there will be after me because those
years of
those are considered an extension of our
prophet Sam
he said in another well-known narration
upon you all is to remain steadfast past
and to hold to my sunnah and the sunnah
of the rightly guided successors after
me. They have a sunnah. Their sunnah is
an extension of his sui.
So he says here there will be after me
after my death and the end of the the
successorship
and some of the beginning stages started
to sprout up at the later years of the
companions era. There will be
there will be leaders
that will
dictate over you. They will be leaders
above you. They will lead you. They will
not be fair.
They will take the goods for themselves.
They will not share what you are owed
with you. And they will bring about
things which you will reject which are
rejected from his sunnah sall.ai
wasam. The companions they said oh
messenger of Allah what do you command
us to do in such a in such an event?
Shall we overthrow them? Shall we fight
them physically? What should we do? And
so he said you give the rights that are
expected of you
and you ask Allah what you expect that
is for you. You give the rights that are
expected of you and you ask Allah for
the rights that you are not being that
are not being fulfilled. Your rights
which are not being fulfilled. And this
is all an expression of the general
statement of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
And do not do not ever
do not
do not ever be treacherous
with someone who has been treacherous
with you.
Do not
do not treat others with e the evil that
they treat you if it is indeed evil.
Here the prophet talks about treachery.
He says do not
use treachery against those who have
used treachery against you.
And so in this narration, our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us of another
type of patience. A patience as a
collective, patience as a society.
This narration has been collected by
both
[Arabic recitation]